well a hundred years ago they went to
113 ballots oh God so this was the third
okay it could be a long night folks just
kidding it could be days I don't know
what's gonna happen I think that with
because he's not able to gain any votes
on the second third maybe even in the
fourth ballot at this point then you
have to say he's already given away a
ton of things to these the small group
of hold out it's like the opposite of
the squad they make the squad look
positively reasonable uh in in this
situation and the a lot of this is just
an ideological thing it might be a
personal thing like I don't like you
okay okay well you know remember when
Nancy Pelosi she held open the vote you
had there was no proxy voting for
speaker there was no proxy voted for
speaker because her numbers were very
very small but they were able to pull
together oh you're saying this is all
secret ballot no no no but last year
remember during covid how she allowed
people to vote from home oh right right
you couldn't do that for the speaker
vote because she needed to have every
single Democrat in the chamber so that
she could become a speaker yes she is
and yeah she was pretty good about
twisting those arms um I think that
conservatives overall in the country
remain deeply dissatisfied with Joe
Biden and every day that the Republicans
are going to spend in this exercise with
their heels digging in with the name
calling started to ratchet up and
they're talking about now internally
within the party enemies you know that
kind of thing is hard to forget and one
of the first things that this group is
going to have to do is come together and
decide whether to raise the debt ceiling
so you thought like this ballot is a is
a tough one wait till you get to that
one we're just getting started with this
kind of drama Greg yeah you know
speaking of drama you know the
difference between that last vote 100
years ago and this one this one's on TV
what are we doing this is what is cause
if this was relegated to C-SPAN we
wouldn't even know it existed right and
and they would probably get through it
but because it's on like our shows now
they're like on the cross okay this is
this is for my future I'm gonna be like
I need to do this and make the people on
Twitter happy or the people or my
buddies in on television you know invite
me more often because you know I'm seen
as feisty giving it to the man but if it
wasn't on this we wouldn't know I
brought us this is why is that I was
gonna ask I want to fast forward through
it when it's up there I want to fast
forward because we know what the
ending's gonna be right the ending is
probably going to be McCarthy but I
couldn't care you don't care I don't
care this is the worst game of chicken
ever it's like it's just a game of
chicken you have a car going at the
other and you wait this is not even that
it's not even even that it's just bad
it's like it's like the Republicans read
a book by the Democrats saying how to
really screw up your party